the first ever marvel studios television
production on disney plus one division
started out as a slow occasionally
creepy bun episode one brought viewers
into the black and white world of
westview what appeared to be a
picture-perfect portrait of suburban
bliss
with wonder maximoff and her synthazoid
husband vision at the center of it all
playing on tropes and aesthetics found
in sitcoms throughout the decades
one division at first appeared to be an
antics of the week's show about an
unlikely couple their nosy neighbor
their community and their co-workers
something clearly wasn't right though
vision died back in avengers infinity
war wonder wasn't even alive in the 50s
60s or 70s
sword has started an investigation into
west view because its residents are real
people who have gone missing
and the person closest to wonder and
vision in this world
isn't who she seems as a marvel
cinematic universe's newest and
strangest production has inched closer
and closer to its end game things have
become slightly more conventional
though by no means less impactful wonder
version episode
8 entitled previously on finally gives
fans some answers
courtesy of recently revealed magical
girl agatha harkness
and her quest to get to the bottom of
wonder's absurd power
set one division episode 8 also explains
to viewers that wonder is
actually an ultra powerful entity that
agatha dubs to scarlet witch
oh and we also find out that wonder
actually never stole vision's dead body
contrary to what sword director tyler
haywood claimed in a previous episode
nine days ago maximoff stormed our
facility
stole the vision's body and resurrected
him
the version of vision we've seen so far
has been wander's own magical creation
which likely explains why he had trouble
leaving the hex in episode 6.
but episode 8 has another arguably even
more shocking color-coded surprise
at the very end by revealing the
mysterious project sword has been
working on
director haywood and his crew have
managed to rebuild the original visions
corpse
and the episode ends with this new
eerily white version reactivating
white vision has a robust history in the
marvel comics
he's basically a resurrected vision
without any of the things that actually
make him vision
sure he looks mostly the same and has
the same powers
however much like his colour his
emotions and innate goodness are
gone essentially he's what director
haywood claims vision is
and what he thinks that synthezoid
should be a weapon
comic book readers first saw vision in
white in the 1989
vision quest storyline of avengers west
coast
in the comic run hank pym is the one who
rebuilds vision
after mockingbird betrays vision and the
avengers by aiding in the abduction of
vision
once vision is captured his body is
dismantled scarlet witch ends up seeing
vision or broken apart and splayed out
before pym rebuilds him the caveat that
crops up during the reassembling process
are twofold
vision's red exterior was too damaged to
be restored so he's now ghostly white
and his mind originally crafted in the
comics by using brainwaves from wonder
man
has been wiped leaving him without the
same mind or memories that he once
possessed
the new vision that boots up isn't the
same one that his fellow heroes know and
love
he's all android no humanity this causes
scarlet witch whose vision's wife at
this point
just like in one division to plummet
into a state of deep
dark sadness at the same time scarlet
witch also comes to find out
shocking revelations about her children
twin sons billy and tommy
who are part of one division as well how
white vision comes to be in one division
is quite different
but the end result is evidently the same
director heywood and his sword team have
been rebuilding vision
as part of project cataract in medical
terms a cataract occurs when proteins in
the lens of one's eye begin to break
down
causing clouding that can make the
affected area of the lens
look white this results in blurred foggy
or otherwise distorted vision
pretty on the nose for what's happening
with the character vision and the show
right
considering that the whole driving force
of one division is wonders deep love for
vision
and her even deeper grief after losing
him one can probably assume that
encountering her lost loves emotionless
reanimated monochrome corpse
will be a bad time for everyone involved
it remains to be seen how the show plans
to deal with this
but considering how good one division is
at pulling the viewer's heart strings
it's probably safe to assume that
episode 9 will be a massive emotional
gut punch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one